uh some breaking news for you uh from
the world of scottish football aberdeen
and celtic's upcoming matches in the
scottish premiership have been postponed
for uh after another player broke
quarantine rules
uh by taking a secret trip to spain uh
this is the celtic defender bolly
bolingoli mumbo he did not self-isolate
after the trip and played in their match
against kilmarnock on
sunday it follows a case of eight
aberdeen players who broke the rules by
visiting a bar
two of the players have since tested a
positive 4k vid19
so three games have now been postponed
they are abdean vs uh
hamilton uh academical and sumerian
versus celtic tomorrow
as well as aberdeen versus celtic on
saturday
so scotland's first minister says the
situation
is unacceptable let's have a listen to
what nicolas sturgeon had to say
i don't want the season to be in
jeopardy and for the reasons i've just
set out i don't want
people who are not responsible for this
to pay the price but we
have to be very clear this situation is
not
acceptable so we'll set out the
conclusion of those talks hopefully
later today i think is a minimum
you should not be expecting to see
aberdeen or celtic play over the course
of the
coming week and we'll set out
conclusions beyond that
by putting this as clearly as i can in
language that the football
um world will understand consider today
the yellow card
the next time it will be the red card
and because you will leave us with
absolutely no choice
let's speak to sky sports news reporter
charles patterson who's in
glasgow um you've been speaking to a
celtics uh manager he's uh he's not a
happy man
yeah that's right gamal this is hugely
embarrassing for celta as well as for
the whole of
scottish football neil lennon it was
apoplectic
with rage at his lunchtime media
conference which came
just before the official confirmation
that tomorrow's game against
sumerian which was just to be broadcast
live on sky sports has been called off
their weekend game
at home to aberdeen as well is now off
as is that aberdeen hamilton game
schedule for tomorrow night this comes
off
obviously hot on the heels of the uh the
eight aberdeen players
who were found to be out in a bar about
10 days ago
two of them tested positive the rest
have been asked to self-isolate for 14
days
and neil lennon described bollywood and
goalie's actions as a complete betrayal
of trust he said the player has given no
rationale for why he went to spain
a week past monday for one night he then
flew back
on the tuesday and then didn't tell
anybody at the club
that he had been abroad of course we
know the
the the lockdown implications with
regards to traveling to spain he then
played at the weekend against kilmarno
he came on as a substitute
so he is now quarantining his future
looks very doubtful indeed
neil lennon wouldn't go so far as to say
this was a sackable offence
but he and every manager in scotland
gamal is aware that scottish football is
on a precipice at the moment the
government intervened
to postpone st johnson against aberdeen
last weekend
after the issues in that city uh arose
and the government are prepared to shut
scottish football down nicola sturgeon
made
that abundantly clear today and it's an
embarrassment
that football has been given special
dispensation to function in a
professional capacity
cannot look after its own house and that
is the message that has been hammered
home to clubs by the government
today they were meeting this morning
with the spfl and sfa
and the authorities have been told sort
yourselves out or we will shut you down
so
it's very much a case of this is the
last warning as far as the government
are concerned if there's another breach
don't be surprised if the government
decides to suspend football altogether